we have electricity and water but as for
the food and medicines uh we don't have
an
enough yeah so each day we have less and
less they are just shooting to the cars
to the people we can't go anywhere Maria
Paul is another southern city surrounded
water food and the power cut off these
people made it to the relative safety of
Donetsk two hours to the north
the house is destroyed husband is dead
they couldn't get his body out for three
days when we were evacuated it took
three days The Lads that let us out
promised to bury him and would later
tell me where my child is on the other
side of the city I know nothing about
her is she even alive
with the water cut off in mariopol the
Ukrainian President says a child has
died there due to dehydration if it is
desperate we heard a lot of
promises
in particular about a humanitarian
corridors for our people in mariopal but
all those humanitarian Corridor
Arrangements did not work we don't have
any more time to wait people in mariopal
have no time to wait the occupiers want
us to die we don't want our people to
die
the road out of the eastern city of Sumi
has opened up for some the condemnation
of Russia Grows by the day inside the
Kremlin President Putin knows that
sanctions are biting at home and he
needs his people on side
I'd like to address the mother's wives
sisters brides and girlfriends of our
soldiers and officers who are in battle
now to defend Russia as part of the
special military operation I know how
worried you are for your loved ones you
can be proud of them just as a whole
country is proud and feels for them
two million people have now left Ukraine
this is what war in Europe looks like
the turmoil is immense it's only 13 days
since Russia invaded
Tom Parmenter Sky News
well let's uh take a look then at the
latest on the ground for you and Ukraine
says the Russian Advance has slowed but
heavy missile and artillery strikes
continue on City centers and civilian
infrastructure
the capital Kiev and other Targets in
the center and east of the country were
hit during the night
local authorities report at least 21
civilians including two children were
killed in an airstrike on a residential
street of Sumi last night
or Russia promised a cease-fire from
this morning to allow civilians to flee
to safety from these five cities
including Sumi local officials there
have reported that the ceasefire has
held and hundreds of civilians have been
evacuated towards poltava in the center
of the country
and Ukraine claims a senior Russian
general was killed yesterday near
kharkiv they put Russian military
casualties at more than 12 000 so far
well these are the latest pictures from
the city of octurka which is less than
70 miles away from kharkiv Sky News has
verified and located this video to the
city center well as you can see it shows
the devastation in the city that has
been the victim of heavy Russian
shelling
and these pictures have been released in
the past few minutes by President
zielinski showing him walking on the
streets of Kiev during the daytime
during the short video he reassures his
audience that everything will be fine
and Ukraine will win the war against
Russia
well Deborah Haynes joins me now from
the train station in the Ukrainian city
of leviv Deborah tell us about the scene
there what are you seeing
it's a desperate scenes really of people
fleeing there this is the station behind
me you can see people moving in there
over the past sort of hour or so since
we've been here they've been long queues
of people and waiting outside one group
that we saw said they've been waiting
for about three hours and then when a
train comes the Train's going to Poland
they get moved inside and then more
people arrive and if you can see people
behind me and if I'd sort of pan around
you can see that back away from the
station there's basically like large
encampments that have been kind of set
up with people
um
volunteers setting up like sort of
little
um fires the sort of there's uh big
metal dustbins you can see over here
um with some warmth givings it's really
cold here as well and then tents an
encampments whether you've got
volunteers giving out food to people
warm drinks
um I saw people handing out blankets as
well and the people that we've spoken to
they've come from across the country
we've spoken to a lot of families that
come from kharkiv in the East
um one lady she was here with a
three-year-old daughter and was saying
to me over the past sort of six or seven
days they'd been living in the basement
she described sort of Rocket fire
outside tanks soldiers her daughter
really scared and they decided to move
here they've just gone in to get the
train to Poland another lady that we
spoke to she's a dancer from Kiev she
was saying to me she just arrived here
today she said it was kind of like it
felt like I'm like a glass of water
where you have a balance of how much you
can tolerate of that water until it gets
to a certain level and then it
overstools and you have to leave and she
described that the just the the daily
bombardments around her neighborhood
outside key for just reached such a
level that she thought today she was
going to have to leave she did and then
just finally another family that we
spoke to it was a mum with three little
three girls a 13 year old an 11 year old
and a seven-year-old and she said that
her husband actually had told her to
take her children take their children
and leave saying it was really important
to look after the children because
they're the future and but she was
really distraught to have left her
husband behind he's still working and
she said that he would be helping with
the sort of the Defense Forces they're
from just around a city called denipro
which is in the South Central uh part of
of Ukraine and this women with their
three children very upset she too was
waiting to get on a train she was
actually waiting to to meet with some
family and then she was going to be
traveling over the Border too to Poland
so literally every single family every
single person here has been wrenched
from their lives they're all so
emotional and frightened about the
future and everybody has a terrible
story that's unimaginable to hear
um and yet this is what's happening
right now in this country it's awful
Deborah security and defense editor live
from the train station at leviv thanks
very much indeed
well the impact of the war in Ukraine
has continued to affect people trying to
leave the country as we just saw there
in leviv Natalia Billick Plum is from
Ukraine but now lives in Surrey her
mother tried to go Tel Aviv to arrange
her visa for the UK but as said the
process is simply too complicated to
leave
so since we've filled that application
form on a Friday for my mom and her and
my all my family
um Visa santel Vive
um suddenly announced on Saturday they
were open and then the evening they
announced they're closed then on Sunday
again they announced they're open so my
mom made her way to leave
and then to hear in in the evening and
on the Sunday they shot again but we
still didn't believe it we thought we'll
still go and check so she's a disabled
imagine disabled woman who struggles to
walk made over way there just only be
told has been shot and she's been told
that the British Embassy came in and
took the equipment away to take to do
the Biometrics and then she had to go
and travel abroad and find her way
abroad and try to get to Visa centers in
Europe
and then if you do need to travel she's
disabled who struggles to walk and even
stand she'll have to travel with her
grandchildren and wait two three days to
the border and then make her way to the
visa center where you're not even
guaranteed to get in on one day so it
means maybe a week or two weeks just
waiting and trying to get into Embassy
there's so many people have applied and
only you can get I don't know 100
appointments in a day so imagine the
cues and imagine the people frustration
and anger trying British British
government says they're going to help
and then you face with this problem
apart from everything else your home and
everything else been lost
it just feels really really hard and not
fair because I can't understand why
people have just submit fingerprints if
they've been here before they'll be
checked when they arrive here why can
you just skip to this process and just
just like to submit application for
murder submit the paperwork online and
then you can have a look and check
everything especially if my mum used to
travel here all the time and her visa
just run down so she can't come in right
now
but they've been here before and she's
been traveling here since since I live
here for the last 17 years
and she never broke any rules any law
a tough experience everyone is going
through right now I'll hear the foreign
secretary Liz truss has said that a
pop-up processing center will open in
Lille in France for Ukrainian refugees
wanting to come to the UK let's bring in
a political correspondent Kate McCann
she's live in Westminster for us today
so some movement now finally Kate as far
as the refugee situation is concerned
and this pop-up visa center being set up
yes that's right the pop-up Center will
be set up in Lille that's around 75
miles away from Calais where we
understand there were around 600
Ukrainian migrants refugees wanting to
get into the United Kingdom now there
had been some confusion overnight about
when the government was setting this new
processing center up and exactly where
it would be we still don't have a formal
location in Lille or a date for when it
will be up and running the understanding
is that the home office
had been hesitant excuse me had been
hesitant to direct people to Lille
before they have this Center up and
running because they know the pressure
it will be under there are many many
thousands of applications of ukrainians
who want to come into the United Kingdom
already around 500 so far have been
accepted but there is pressure not just
on those processing centers where
biometric data is gathered and you just
heard there about the confusion around
why that is being collected the UK
government is saying that there are
security reasons for that in fact a
minister in the House of Commons just a
short while ago said that I had they had
already had examples of people turning
up at Borders trying to say that they
were Ukrainian trying to get into the
United Kingdom so the government
believes it's important to keep those
Security checks in place but they do
slow this process down and the pressure
is not just on those visa application
centers in countries like France but
also in Poland where over a million now
refugees have crossed into Poland from
Ukraine trying to make that onward
Journey I've just been speaking into
someone in one of those centers in
Poland who described the situation on
the ground there as chaotic that there
were over a hundred people currently
waiting in the center to be processed
with no idea of a time for an
appointment the computer system is down
there is no formal information being
given out by the handful of staff there
who themselves don't seem to understand
the process or know exactly what's going
to happen next there are elderly people
there are children there waiting there
are not enough chairs there's no food
it's very cold this situation is not
working as the home office would hope
that it is and there is a real mood of
frustration actually in the House of
Commons now for an urgent question to
the home office about how to improve it
across the house from labor MPS from
conservatives saying this is not good
enough we can see these people they are
in desperate need why are we not doing
more more quickly so those questions
persist for the Home Secretary and
they're coming from labor two the shadow
Home Secretary that Cooper had this to
say just a short time ago
yesterday the Home Secretary told the
house twice that a visa center on route
to Calais has now been set up but it
still doesn't exist the foreign
secretary just said it might be in Lille
over nearly 75 miles from Calais the
home office said this morning that no
decision had been taken well which is it
has it where is it can people get there
yet
okay while the refugee crisis is under
discussion the Prime Minister has been
meeting with the so-called vizguard four
and this evening and historic event in
the houses of Parliament prime minister
Vladimir zelenski is due to address the
House of Commons yes that address in the
Commons at five o'clock this afternoon
will be groundbreaking it's never
happened before those who speak in the
Commons have always been MPS up until
this point so Mr zolan zelenski's
address will be a landmark moment huge
screens have been erected in the Commons
and there will be simultaneous
translation for MPS to hear him speak
and I don't expect that it will be a
comfortable listen while the UK has
provided significant amounts of military
support and is doing increasing amounts
of work on the humanitarian side I think
it's fair to say that the Ukrainian
government is frustrated that there is
not a no-fly zone there is pressure on
Boris Johnson to instigate that and to
go further on the issue of planes
potentially from Poland to assist the
ukrainians in their air defense system
now that is decision for the Polish
government the defense secretary Ben
Wallace this morning said he would
support Poland whatever decision they
made but it is complicated it would
potentially be an escalation on the eyes
of in the eyes of Russia which could
cause some difficulties for Poland
itself but the Prime Minister as you say
meeting with that group from the Czech
Republic Slovakia Poland and Hungary
today those meetings focused on what
more can be done on the humanitarian
side and we've been talking about the
Visa situation but there is now a real
pressing need to ensure that
humanitarian corridors are set up the
aid is in the right place and also that
countries like the UK are supporting
Poland who are seeing the brunt of those
huge number of people fleeing over the
Border
okay thanks very much indeed for keeping
us up to date on what's happening in
Westminster
well breaking news um the queen has held
two virtual audiences today at Windsor
Castle she greeted the High Commissioner
of India and the ambassador of Armenia
who spoke to her via video link from
Buckingham Palace while it follows her
in-person meeting with the Canadian
Prime Minister Justin frudo yesterday
the first since she was diagnosed with
covid last month
well let's take you back to the
situation with refugees fleeing Ukraine
Skies Ashner harinag is in Calais where
many refugees trying to get to the UK
remain stranded and she sent us this
latest
I mean even just to find this particular
Center that's been um put up when I say
Center though that is quite an
exaggeration is simply a table for
people to come and get leaflets and
information over the next steps people
are being advised if they come to Calais
that actually you've got to travel back
in the direction they came from you've
got to go to a visa application center
in Brussels or Paris there is some
swirling suggestions that Lil might be a
temporary facility that might be put up
but there is no suggestion that Cali is
to get any form of application center
for these people that have had such a
traumatic journey to get to this point
now either these people
um are wanting to go to the UK to seek a
sanctuary or they know someone that
lives there they've got some form of
relative and perhaps they've got some
connection which means that they're able
to be fast tracked for a Visa except
there is so much paperwork to do now for
any British person it is complicated but
for people that perhaps have English as
a second language it is even more more
strenuous and stressful to do one
charity that's helping people here in
Calais is care for Calais they've got so
much experience helping refugees we
spoke to Claire Mosley the founder of
that charity just an hour hour ago
140 people stayed here last night and
they confirmed that for me and I know
that some of them have gone to Paris
they're being sent to Paris some of them
have got interviews there but a lot of
them haven't and my concern is that
there's nobody there to help them
because we turned up here to help them
but there was nobody else I'm not sure
there's anybody in Paris and if you
don't speak English how are you going to
fill in these forms they're very tired
they've had a very adrenaline filled few
weeks they are scared for their
relatives a lot of them will have family
members who are right now fighting with
the Ukraine Army
yet another hurdle for many of these
people to cross one family that Claire
spoke to said that they had just been
given radiation sickness tablets because
they're from a part of Ukraine which is
near the power plant and if you remember
that came Under Fire a few days ago
people here have been through so much
trauma they are exhausted and yet this
extra hurdle they're having to cross to
finally get to the UK is proving too
much for many
um but it seemed as though you know
there are about 150 people stuck in that
position currently and that number is
only going to grow
[Music]
well energy giant shell has said it will
stop buying Russian oil natural gas and
close its service stations in Russia it
comes amid sanctions that have meant the
price of all has reached a 14-year high
and Russia has warned it could cut gas
supplies to Europe well a short time ago
the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken said we need to stop depending
on Russian energy as they'll use it as a
weapon
we want to make sure that energy is is
uh is widely available at the same time
as the
uh prime minister said
there is I think a significant
not only opportunity but imperative uh
In This Moment
to finally move off of for many
countries in Europe dependence on
Russian energy
because
Russia uses it as a weapon and we're
seeing countries respond to that we're
working closely with them as they as
they engage in those efforts it will
take as the Prime Minister said some
time to do that but if you'll forgive
the bad pun there is real energy in this
in this effort
foreign
King joins me now Ian talk us through
this huge ramifications aren't there for
what's going on right now well there are
and this actually gets to the nub of the
issue because in the last hour we've had
a speech from Jonathan brilly he's the
chief executive of off gem the energy
regulator here during which he has been
talking about the need longer term for
uh the UK and other energy consumers to
wean themselves off gas obviously uh the
longer term ambition is to move fully to
Renewables but I'll just read you out a
couple of the uh lines from this speech
by Jonathan brilli because they are very
very interesting indeed he says last
Autumn unlined the fact that our
Reliance on gas led us exposed to
extreme volatility and extreme prices
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has made
that reality even more Stark I have been
working in energy and climate change for
many years longer than I care to admit
but I have never seen a situation like
this indeed I cannot find a similar
situation in our post-war energy history
and Jonathan brilly goes on to say while
it is too early to predict what the
price cap will be in October a price
increase is almost inevitable now bear
in mind that off gem has just announced
an increase in the energy household
price cap to
1971 pounds that kicks in at the
beginning of April well Jonathan brilli
putting consumers on notice there that
there will be a further increase in due
course in October when the price cap
next comes under review so that is
pretty terrible news for all UK
households but I think what is really
interesting there is that Jonathan
brilli is saying he doesn't think
there's been a situation like this in
this country's post-war energy history
and bear in mind if you think back to
the 1973 1974 oil shock which obviously
followed the Yom Kippur War in which
Israel was invaded by its Arab neighbors
the West piled in to support Israel on
that and the OPEC cartel subsequently
introduced oil embargoes against the
United States the UK Netherlands Japan
and other Western countries well that
sparked a recession in more or less the
whole of the West Western World at that
time and Jonathan breely is saying in
effect that that situation has nothing
on what we're looking at now I think
that is a very very troubling statement
indeed from the energy regulator in the
last few minutes we've also had some
comments from fatay Biro he is the
director general of the International
Energy agency now you'll recall that on
Friday the iea announced a coordinated
release of some 60 million barrels of
oil from member countries uh fatty
Barrel has been speaking to the
financial times and he said that there
is plenty more to come on that front
from the iea he's pointed out that that
release on Friday only represented four
percent of the oil reserves of iea
member countries and that potentially
there could be a lot more to come so I
think you are looking at a coordinated
release again of iea reserves in an
attempt to bring down oil and gas prices
uh Brent crude a short while ago by the
way trading it to
126.47 cents a barrel that is up three
and a quarter percent on the session
natural gas gas prices interestingly
have come off the boil right now
currently trading at four pounds 75 p a
therm and bear in mind yesterday the
price hit eight pounds a thumb which was
a significant increase bear in mind just
before Christmas when we were talking
with great concern about uh wholesale
gas prices at that point in time the
price was around 265 of them so we are
still at elevated levels compared with
that pre-Christmas Panic that we had
Ian thank you
you're watching Sky News well stay tuned
after the break we'll bring you the very
latest from our special correspondent
Alex Crawford in Kiev
[Music]
thank you
I am there to speak truth to power one
question to ask questions that people
won't ask when I'm interviewing a
politician it's a more rapid fire but
this is not this is a conversation the
format of the show so we're going to
have an hour-long interview show Once
week on the Thursday night it's at 9pm
it's a moment to press pause on this
frenetic pace of news and just reflect
on things and when we do have a
politician on the show you might see
them interviewed by me in a different
way than you perhaps normally see it
what they do why they do it if I can
find some of that and bring it on to Sky
News I'll be really happy
[Music]
Ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with Russian
soldiers Air Raid Sirens through the
Airways in the distance artillery Rains
Down it feels very close to the center
of there's one they found this
Devastation to their apartment lots of
people live here quite a few of the
windows of the houses have been blown
out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave I'm
Greg mylam Sky's U.S correspondent here
in Los Angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those winds strong enough to bend and
twist metal
you try to run me over so Philip no go
away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so Philip can you go away
I've seen the Dark Side of America
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of America's opioid cross
[Music]
I've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
Christchurch has been changed Forever by
what happened
[Music]
back while hundreds of ukrainians have
been streaming out of European town near
Kiev to get away from the advancing
Russian forces which appear to be headed
for the capital a special correspondent
Alex Crawford has the latest from Urban
this is an absolutely desperate scene
you can see people who are elderly who
are frail who are unable to cross
themselves having to be carried over
this tiny little plank there's a real
urgency here amongst the soldiers and
those who are trying to get them over
because they don't know how long this
Lull in the fighting is going to
continue we've heard a bit of um
shelling but it's mostly coming from
this side and there's clearly a huge
number of people waiting still anxious
to get over we understand from the
Ukrainian officials that there are about
4 000 people also trapped not just in
the urban but coming from Butcher and
hostile so there's a a real frantic
urgency about trying to get them over
and out of of this area which has come
under attack several times over the last
few days the incredible scene there are
dozens of people like this man who are
having to be held and taken over a
really hairiest rickety bridge and do it
slowly because you can't have too many
people on that bridge at one time or
else it will just snap and they're
trying to do this quickly before the
firing starts again
Alex Crawford in Earth in there well our
security and defense analyst Michael
Clark will be answering your questions
on the Ukraine crisis in a live q a at 7
pm tonight you can enter a question just
email us at Sky News News at sky.com or
you can find us on Twitter at Sky News
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to
today's edition of The Sky News Daily
podcast today our correspondent inzaman
Rasheed looks at whether more could be
done by the UK government to help
Ukrainian refugees get into Britain he
hears from those trying to enter the
country and takes a look at how the UK
Visa schemes work you can subscribe to
the Daily wherever you get your podcasts
this is Sky News Today coming up we'll
get more on the situation in Ukraine
with Enver Solomon the chief executive
of the refugee Council
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the war in Ukraine has led to the
biggest movement of people in Europe
since the second world war the U.N
Refugee agency says more than two
million people have now fled Ukraine of
those more than 1.2 million of them have
crossed into Poland over 190
000 have gone to Hungary which has
changed its earlier Hardline policy on
accepting refugees 140
000 have crossed into Slovakia more than
80 000 Ukrainian residents are now in
Moldova while a similar number are in
Romania it's important to note that huge
numbers have already passed through
after arriving in these countries more
than 200 000
210 000 in fact are now in other
European countries uh nearly a hundred
thousand are reported to have left for
Russia
well we're joined Now by Emma Solomon
chief executive of the refugee Council
thanks very much indeed for speaking to
us at what must be an incredibly uh busy
time for you do you think uh not just
neighboring countries but wider areas
are around the world and and Europe in
particular has responded quickly enough
to deal with this Refugee crisis
I think it's positive that the European
Union has made a very strong commitment
to take any Ukrainian into the EU and
allow them to stay in the EU for up to
three years but I'm concerned that the
UK is playing catch-up we have just
taken 300 ukrainians the family scheme
the family Visa scheme the government
has announced is very narrow it's very
restrictive and we've yet to have any of
the details of any offer that's going to
be made to ukrainians this is the worst
Refugee crisis it looks as though it's
going to be the worst Refugee crisis
since the second world war and I think
you know the British people want the UK
government to send a clear sign a clear
signal rather to any Ukrainian that
they're welcome in the UK if they want
to come there
it is extraordinary you mentioned that
number 300 visas compared with 17
000 scheme applications it is
extraordinary there's uh criticism upon
criticism but really the UK has always
been a little out of step with the
international Refugee crisis hasn't it
and and there's a lot of criticism about
um the the UK or often shutting its
borders to refugees
that's right and I think this is a
political position and decision that the
government's taken but it it's it's
rather I think out of state with where
the public is at the moment particularly
on Ukraine and it's out of Step of of
our history and our background as a
nation because after the horrors of the
two second world wars back in 1951 we
were one of the Nations that came
together with others and signed the U.N
convention on refugees that's the most
important International treaty and what
it says is that anyone who's fleeing War
conflict Bloodshed persecution should
have the opportunity to be granted
Refugee status in a country of their
choosing and I struggle to understand
today why the government is dragging its
feeds and isn't making a very clear
commitment to any Ukrainian that they'll
be welcomed here as a refugee and will
will support them to come here as a
refugee and give them the sanctuary that
they need
um I want to talk to you about uh
children who've been left on their own
there was a striking image that we had
on Sky News of a young boy sobbing
walking along on his own what what's the
situation as far as lone children are
concerned
it's a really important question I'm
glad you've raised this because we're
hearing information that there could be
tens of thousands of children who have
been left on their on their own who are
effectively become known as as what are
called unaccompanied refugees and that's
because their parents have wanted to get
them to safety or they've told them to
flee by themselves because they haven't
been able to be with them or they have
other things you know that they have to
fight they have to defend they have to
look after others in Ukraine so we're
facing a situation where I think they're
going to be tens of thousands of
children
who have left Ukraine by themselves and
what we're calling for is that the UK
Works rapidly with its European Partners
to provide a dedicated scheme so that
these children can be kept safe they can
be granted what's known as safe passage
to the UK and other European countries
and briefly I want to ask you about your
work
will help with internally
it's not just people fleeing Ukraine but
those inside who are now homeless who
are fleeing the humanitarian corridors
are allegedly being shelled today just
in the last couple of hours we've had a
report of that that Russian forces are
shelling one of the agreed humanitarian
corridors coming out of Maria Paul what
more can be done to help those people
a really shocking and deeply disturbing
reports about the situation for for all
those people we don't work with
internally displaced people but there
are other agencies International
agencies on the ground who will be
looking to support them and I think it's
it's absolutely vital that they are
given all the support they need by the
International Community because as you
say it's not just the more than two
million people that have fled Ukraine
but there's lots of people within
Ukraine who have had to seek safety in
other parts of the country and it's
vital that they get the aid and the
support that they need the challenges
it's very difficult for eight agencies
to get into Ukraine at the moment
obviously because of the security
situation but it's really important that
we don't forget those people and that
the International Community and the UK
government comes together and ensures
that everything is done to give them the
support that they need because their
likelihood is as the conflicts continue
use they will then become refugees who
will flee Ukraine so that number of two
up two million refugees today is likely
to increase to to many more in the
coming days and weeks
Amber Solomon from the refugee Council
thanks very much indeed
bring you some breaking news now and the
UN Human Rights office says the latest
toll in Ukraine since February the 22nd
is 1
335 civilian casualties including
474 killed and
861 injured so those are the very latest
figures coming to us from UN Human
Rights office
well let's take a closer look now at the
Strategic situation on the ground in
Ukraine Sky's Anna Jones and General Sir
Richard Barons have been discussing the
attempt to set up humanitarian corridors
in the country
Roots out for civilians from five cities
in Ukraine chernoheve Kiev Sumi kharkiv
and mariopol so is it clear where
civilians would be evacuated to through
these corridors so it's clear that the
humanitarian drama is one of the
defining features of of this conflict
with two million having left Ukraine so
far and and the UN talking about maybe 5
million wanting to move and they're
moving on one of three options the the
first is to move from a city that's
being attacked somewhere else in Ukraine
which is at least for now safe from the
shelling but it begs the question as to
how terrible that will be in the medium
term the second option by far the
preferred option for many ukrainians is
to move from the East and center of
Ukraine West into particularly Poland
and the European Union almost 2 million
in fact two million so far and the third
option which Russia has offered is to
move into Belarus or Russia that's not
an attractive offer to many ukrainians
who have been shelled out of their homes
by Russians well yes and we are getting
reports
position is underway out of Sumi but to
the San
within Ukraine so that
that the question of why would you move
people inside a country which is under
attack so they're certainly moving from
a place that's not safe now to a place
that's safe today the question is well
how long is that safe if the Russian
Advance continues and they immediately
repeat the tactics later on okay let's
take a look then what's going on in the
south of the country now and we want to
focus in on Mario poll up there to the
east now this city has been under
bombardment for days now hasn't it from
Russian forces it is still in Ukrainian
control but are we seeing a change of
strategy as far as the Russians are
concerned towards civilians in places
like maripole so we may be the thing
that's been clear from the start is
Russian forces will come out of Crimea
and and head east to link Russia to
Crimea by by land that fight initially
was focused on the Ukrainian military
what we're seeing now are very clear
signs of the Russians directing force
not at the military but at the civilian
population so turning off power water
and Food Supplies shelling residential
areas and has become very clear in
mariopol shelling these evacuation
routes this doesn't appear to be an
accident this is about ratcheting up the
pressure on Ukrainian government by
directly targeting the civilian
population so we're going to see more of
that you think we should expect to see
more of that yes okay and let's take a
look at some of the other port cities as
well because we've got kerson which is
in Russian hands we also have Odessa
which is in Ukrainian hands for the time
being but again Russian forces advancing
on Odessa why are these port cities so
important so the assessment remains that
Russia would come out of Crimea turn
East to close the coast by connecting to
Russia and go west to Odessa if they're
successful in that and they own all the
ports on the Black Sea they isolate the
Ukrainian economy from the sea and
Ukraine exports a great deal of
agricultural produce particularly wheat
and also a lot of things like uranium or
and titanium or the Ukrainian economy
relies on access to the Sea and Russia
if it heads on this current trajectory
is trying to remove that so the South
and the port is very important but also
to North the capital Kiev again crucial
here are still under Ukrainian control
but but Russian forces are moving in how
vulnerable is Kiev do you think today so
much as we're seeing the key economic
that probably in the South what we are
clearly seeing and this has been
unfolding ever since day one our Russian
forces moving on kievas the political
center of gravity and these advances as
you're indicating here are about getting
around the edge of the city perhaps
trying to encircle it but it's a city
three times the size of Manchester so
it's a really big big objective what
we're seeing now is fighting on the
cities that are outside Kiev and on the
on the outskirts of Kev what we should
expect to see over the coming days is
the sort of tactics we've seen in places
like cargive and sunny beginning to
appear on on Kiev to put pressure on the
government and overall what should we be
looking out for in Ukraine over the next
few days so I think we're going to see
three things unfold concurrently over
the next few days and they're all about
putting pressure on the Ukrainian
government the first is the attempt to
complete that movement in the South to
disconnect the economy from the sea and
to take Odessa the second is the is the
second is the movement on the government
in in Kiev that's some days away now but
that's likely directed up and the third
will be dialing up the pain on the Civil
population deliberately in order to try
and get Kiev to sue for peace
this is Sky News Today coming up more
than 2 million people have now fled
Ukraine with warnings the number could
rise to 5 million I'll speak to the un's
refugee agency live from the Ukrainian
Polish border
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to Myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
clear
[Applause]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
traffic jam snake for hours up and down
this Hillside it means precious age con
access those in needs
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
I think experiencing the two million
person March in Hong Kong that was a
moment
I don't like the Chinese government it's
cruel
[Music]
it was real people power in action
yeah
please have been foreign
[Music]
Robins Sky News
I'm Becky Johnson a Sky News Midlands
correspondent based here in Birmingham
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
welcome back two million people have now
fled Ukraine according to the U.N
Refugee agency European Union officials
have said that number could rise to 5
million well Matthew salt marsh is head
of news and media for the UN Refugee
agency and joins us now from madika on
the Polish side of the border with
Ukraine
um tell us uh Matthew what the situation
is at madika right now
well it's slightly quieter than it has
been in some recent days but that
doesn't necessarily tell us anything as
you mentioned uh now over 2 million
people have left Ukraine the neighboring
countries and here in Poland the numbers
well over a million now uh so well over
half of the total
it all very much depends on what happens
on the ground in Ukraine as to how many
people uh come through we know that
there are a number of people over in the
red who are considering coming over
depending on the degree of the conflict
in the country so a little bit quieter
right now but that doesn't necessarily
mean anything
yeah and you will have been speaking to
people who have been crossing the border
what are they telling you about what
they've been through
well many of the people have come from
over to the east of the country uh and
then just trying to get over West and
get over the border and what we've
noticed is that the people who are
crossing now perhaps compared to the
earlier days of this crisis uh have less
resources
um less means
um still obviously it's women and
children
um but maybe slightly more vulnerable
cases
um and maybe those people who don't know
where they're going to go on to they
might not have the networks and the
connections so they'll be perhaps more
reliant on in this case Poland and the
support the great support that that
country has shown
um and then they'll have to start to
make decisions at some point as to where
they're going to stay where they're
going to live where their children might
go into education and so on
yeah you you were at a train station I
understand earlier this morning as well
in another location can you tell us
about the situation there that was
receiving direct trains from the Viv
um it was very very busy lots of civil
society and humanitarian actors were
there providing hot meals uh some space
safe spaces for the women's and quiet
areas
arrivals will come in waves uh it would
go quiet for a few minutes and then a
train will come in and then the station
would fill up there were buses outside
uh that would take people on to other
destinations in Poland
um there is a lot of criticism as well
as concern that the UK has not set up uh
the uh application process fast enough
or or getting visas granted fast enough
for people who want to come here uh
first of all what how do you feel about
the situation and as far as the UK
Authority's handling of this and
secondly are you meeting a lot of people
who want to come to the UK
well the first thing is to say that you
know the EU moved very quickly with its
temporary protection director and that
was really important to give Ukrainian
refugees that security and it also
allows them to rebuild their lives and
to integrate into those countries in
Europe
as to the UK obviously we've had brexit
the UK is outside the EU now it it has
more leeway on those kind of decisions
but our message to the UK would be
um join you know join with those other
countries and try and play as big a role
as you feel is possible and try to
welcome because these people are are
increasingly in a very desperate
situation having experienced what
they've experienced just over that order
over them
we're going to leave it there thanks
very much indeed Matthew salt marsh head
of news and media for
the UN Refugee agency
okay we're breaking news the Russian
defense Ministry says 723 people
evacuated through Sumi poltava
evacuation Corridor including
576 Indian Nationals so that's coming to
us from the Russian defense Ministry
which claims that 723 people have been
evacuated
let's take a quick look at the weather
for you now
[Music]
look forward to brighter Skies the
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days will bring spells
of wind and rain but Eastern parts will
stay largely fine the rest of the
afternoon will be windy with Gales in
the west locally severe near
Northwestern coasts much of Eastern
Scotland and Central and Eastern England
will be dry with the Far East holding
onto the sunshine the rest of the UK
will see cloud and outbreaks of rain but
the Southwest will turn drier and
brighter later meanwhile Ireland can
expect a mix of Sunny spells and heavy
showers the girls in the west will ease
during the evening Eastern parts will
see a little rain moving through
overnight but it won't amount too much
in the south then most places look dry
but Western Island and the Hebrides will
turn wet later the wind will pick up
again too
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News more of our
continuing coverage from Ukraine on day
13 of the war more than 2 million people
have now fled Ukraine
[Music]